would you be open to selling that shield  uh well then she might say to you uh  who's asking what's your name my name is  tarnis  of the house  bottom felt bottom felt  soft  i think  i think i've got some felt i've read uh  i've read pamphlets from the bottom felt  house and they're very racy well yes  well i some of them have center  centerfolds you know my sister  that's your sister  susan bottom felt  well tarnished tarnished bottom felt and  i need a shield  for my next adventure oh what is your  next adventure i don't i don't at this  point well then it's fortuitous that  we've met for i have an adventure to  send you one oh good  see see and then it just goes from there  guys we could keep going for hours but  we're not gonna because this is a  podcast  [Music]  with me and hold me tight all through  the night you're shining bright i'm your  host  [Music]